hey everyone so a little while ago I had
the chance to go and play the Dark Souls
2 TGS demo and I took that chance I
bought two tickets to the eb games expo
and i managed to get about an hour with
the game overall on one of those days i
was even able to record a playthrough
and this is it that's what you're saying
I know the footage looks like it was
recorded with a potato but trust me the
game itself looks great it was running
on a Playstation 3 and graphically
speaking it's really amazing what
they're able to squeeze out of the
consoles at this point anyway we should
talk about graphics later I'm going to
try and commentate over the footage so
right now you see me attempting a parry
and that's something we should talk
about
so parrying has changed when you press
the button down there's a half second
delay before you perform the parry
itself so now you have to actually
predict when an enemy's attack is going
to connect you might think this would
make things harder but it's really not
that bad I managed to get parries
without too much trouble and I think
this is actually because the parry
window itself is a little bit more
forgiving so another thing you'll have
noticed when I parried that guy back
there is that when I parried him he fell
flat on his back this is actually
looking like a really effective method
of crowd control bear in mind that we
know two things one enemies come at you
more in packs now taking one of them out
with a parry and dealing with it later
that sounds like a really viable
strategy and two you can now get damaged
while you're performing the riposte
so knocking an enemy flat with a parry
and dealing the repost a little later
when you have better positioning is an
interesting change so once the enemy is
flat on his back you perform the riposte
all of which look amazing by the way
everyone I've seen so far with every
weapon looks pretty damn sweet so right
here you'll notice that I'm taking our
two enemies um these guys were initially
lying down pretending to be dead there
were so many ambushes in this level so
many enemies pretending to be dead that
would come at you later in the level
anyway you'll notice I took them out
with my short sword but I actually
attacked each one individually instead
of trying to cleave them both with one
swing and that's because there's a new
change to cleaving I think the ability
to damage more than one enemy with one
swing with my huge sword you'll notice I
did a cleave that damaged both enemies
but this doesn't actually seem to be
possible with the short sword I'm pretty
sure you can only hit one enemy at a
time with
small weapon swing which is an
interesting change we know that strength
weapons were underpowered in Dark Souls
and this seems to be just one of the
many ways in which strength weapons seem
to be getting above and speaking of
things that get above this bow was
really great but have a listen to what
happens here
it's pretty good what is
so these guys will surprise you they
have these running attacks where they
run at you and keep running only
stopping when they're able to swipe at
you and that's what happened there there
are really hard to deal with in melee
killing them as a mage was easy so I
assumed the bow would be a good choice
and it works pretty damn well combat
with the bow has definitely changed
as you can see loosing an arrow consumes
stamina now arrows travel faster than 1
mile per hour and arrows are able to be
loosed in quick succession while moving
also first-person aiming felt a lot more
accurate it wasn't as jumping as it is
in Dark Souls and all of this simply
points to bow builds being a really
viable way to complete the game so now
as I venture back into the dark take
note of how amazing that lighting looks
and this is on ps3 to remember just look
at those shadows mount awesome a few
notes about the environment here this
guy throws fire bombs which can blow up
and parts of the environment
you see there's black barrels to the
left there there's a little shortcut
there that a friend found it saves you a
lot of risks and takes you straight to a
bonfire I didn't take it this time
though I wanted to play through this bit
this next section can be can be really
quite tricky so I've been thinking about
it for a while and this demo really was
quite perfect
I mean level design was pretty clever
it's the small things that matter
little things like placing a door here
means that you won't be able to run past
enemies is easy enemies have sprinting
animations now and they can kill you
while you're opening a door in fact they
can kill you while you're doing pretty
much every animation there's a lot of
narrow areas areas where you had to
actually kill things in your way to
progress if you didn't kill them then
they'd come at you later while your
bottlenecked in another area and in Dark
Souls it was really easy to run past
enemies if you'd played for a long time
I have a feeling it's going to be harder
this time around another thing is the
choice of enemies
so these soldier enemies they were quite
easy so that anyone of the convention
could play but there were so many
ambushes true to the style of a Souls
game also it's worth noting that the
demo was loaded with life gems which can
be consumed over time to regain health
almost every enemy dropped one so it was
pretty obvious that they were placed
there just to make the demo easier I
doubt there'll be that abundant in the
fine
version in fact it's actually hard to
say how much of this will even be in the
final version always keep in mind when
you're judging dark souls2 footage
remember that we're like five months out
from the actual release a lot can change
alright so right now we're taking out
these two guys with this amazing sword I
have to say I love this sword
I love how strength weapons are shaping
up in general I mentioned that they seem
to be the only weapons with a cleave now
but there's a few other things for
example remember in Dark Souls when you
got hit by an enemy while you were
shielding you took damage to your
stamina bar well in Dark Souls 2 guard
braking it's going to be a really big
deal so when you increase your strength
stat in Dark Souls 2 you'll do more
stamina damage to an enemy or an enemy
player who is shielding what this
basically means is that strength weapons
will break guards much more easily and
wait for it you remember resistance that
useless stat in Dark Souls while it's
making a comeback increase your
resistance stat and you lose less
stamina from blocking awesome right
it might actually be useful this time
around so this was a scary part in the
demo this guy comes running at me and I
only just roll out of the way here I run
into the dark and I start chasing him
with arrows I'll cut that bit up so here
we'll talk about back stabs for a second
this guy hits me awhile and you'll
notice enemies still are susceptible to
back steps but they only seem to be
susceptible to back stabs when they're
finished attacking when they've messed
up when you've baited them into a
backstab that's when you can backstab if
you just try to fish for a backstab you
won't have that much success so right
now I chase down the final red phantom
this guy has a ton of health and he does
more damage than a regular turtle Knight
he was pretty hard to take out but like
everything else in this demo it's about
picking the right time to attack and
having good movement combat feels
different but in more subtle ways let me
explain
you'll notice for example enemies
haven't been bouncing back off my shield
in addition to this enemy attacks flow
really well it's not like they attack
and then stop which was common in Dark
Souls no the enemies we've seen in this
demo they'll attack you with a flowing
move set with three or four strikes that
are more difficult to predict if you get
caught by one of these strikes you'll
likely get hit by the rest
in addition to this remember
invincibility frames and Dark Souls in
Dark Souls you had one frame in which
you are invincible while rolling well
they're still in Dark Souls 2 but I'd
say that your invincibility frames are
about two-thirds is small this time
around definitely a bit harder to get
all of this means movement is more
important which reflects another change
I noticed I played every class and some
of them had way more fluid movement than
others rolling was incredibly fast on
the dual swordsman and in addition he
moved more fluidly turning around was
faster running was faster walking was
faster everything just felt smoother and
you had better control over your
movement and better control over an
encounter with an enemy which I think is
going to be really important with the
temple Knight in contrast rolling was
slower and so was overall movement I
could be wrong but I don't think I am
there's a bigger emphasis on movement
while managing multiple enemies this
time around I want speaking of multiple
enemies this part was difficult these
four guys come at you with these combos
that can easily take you out if you get
hit by more than two at once so I
eventually decide that taking them on in
this room that's a really bad idea
they're much easier to handle if they're
in a corridor where you can funnel them
and hit multiple at once and once again
we see that great Souls level design
where you use your environment to your
advantage and use that to make things
easier I managed to capture about 18
minutes worth of footage and all of it
was pretty good I'll only show you guys
about 10 minutes of it here I don't want
to link too much every time I play
through though I played through without
too much trouble keep in mind that I
played the demo a few times in the
footage you've seen so I've already
memorized enemy locations and I had a
slightly easier time than the first time
I played so in closing the difficulty
was still there that made me and a
couple of friends played and we managed
to get to the Maronite a couple of times
but all around us not many people were
fighting the Maronite and mostly you
could just hear the sounds of people
dying so I assume it was fairly hard for
everyone else a friend got him to 20%
health on his first try I managed to get
the Maronite down on my second go we
faced him with this mage character first
which actually made the fight a little
bit easier but remember as well as that
this was a demo loaded with life gems
which
use to heal yourself and we don't even
know if this will reflect the final game
also remember that in this demo the
Maronite didn't summon human players he
summoned NPCs I couldn't figure out how
to stop him summoning players so if he's
summoning real players he's going to be
one hell of a box he summoned like three
players average everytime I fought him
it's gonna be a pretty intense fight if
you're fighting real people instead of
NPCs I can tell you that much
anyway guys thanks for watching I'm
gonna leave you with my death against
the Maronite I got overconfident at the
end I let him summon someone and let him
live because I really wanted to parry
him and show you what that would be like
but unfortunately I died and that's the
screen I'm gonna have to get used to
seeing again anyway later guys I'll
catch you next time Dark Souls 2 is
shaping up to be a much more difficult
game than its predecessor welcome again
guys two souls news an embargo has just
lifted on some more details about Dark
Souls 2 and these these are probably the
best facts we've heard for a while so
sit back relax and let me share them
with you if you want to skip ahead to
something more interesting
check the description the three biggest
pieces of news are as follows one